I've always been a huge fan of silent
films especially Buster Keaton and when
his films were released on DVD I noticed
that he filmed a chasing in north beach
in San Francisco where he used to live
so just sort of on a whim I decided to
see if I could track those locations
down and i did so rather easily and i
don't know for some reason I've just
enjoyed the you know the problem solving
the the thing about silent films that
were filmed on location they actually
were filmed in a real spot and that real
spot still exists somewhere and some
other challenge of tracking it down was
always very appealing to me and so it
was just sort of a simple hobby that
grew into a series of books well one of
the things that I've noticed in tracking
down those locations if you can find a
spot the filmmakers were often very
efficient so often they would film on
one street corner but turn the camera
north and south and east and west and so
sometimes if you find that one shot
you'll writ and you go to the spot in
person you'll realize that they film
several other scenes there as well one
thing that I found very interesting
especially with Buster Keaton he would
travel miles and miles to find the
perfect setting for that for his gag but
on the other hand if he just needed a
simple shot of someone walking down the
street he would film them literally
right across the street from his studio
and if you know what you're looking for
in all of his films you'll see scene
after scene that's filmed right across
the street from from his studio well the
the area of hollywood and cahuenga the
block of cahuenga south of hollywood
boulevard was a very popular place to
film and Harold Lloyd and Buster Keaton
both filmed several scenes from their
movies there and it's you can literally
walk down the street and building after
building after building you can say you
know Harold filmed here Buster filmed
here it's it's not something that's
readily apparent unless you put all the
pieces together but it makes sense that
the time especially in the early 20s
there weren't a great number of
commercial districts from which they
could choose to shoot and so Hollywood
Boulevard and cahuenga it was close to
their studios and so it was only natural
they would they would go there if they
needed a simple shot of someone walking
you know by a shop window or something
one other thing that's really quaint if
you study what's going on
the background of these films you can
see people in the background you know
they're very respectfully standing and
waiting but in in some of the early
Chaplin films when he's coming in and
out of a storefront you can see the
reflection of people in the windows you
can see people down the street and so
there was a there's always been a great
fascination in watching people shoot
films but even from the very beginning
and I think it's really quaint because
nowadays they would use CGI to erase the
people or have police chase them away
but you know there are people's great
grandparents who are unintentionally in
the background of some of these classic
films
you